[Music]
hey everyone
just a very quick video for you guys i'm
going to be showing you some footage
that was leaked from the new harry
potter game
hogwarts legacy i'm going to be making
another video
later today that is more my normal
format video
but i saw that this footage had leaked
and wanted to share it with you
for those that don't know the game is an
open world format harry potter game
that takes place in the late 1800s a
hundred years before harry
ever set foot in the school if you want
to check out the full trailer
it's available on the playstation
youtube channel an open world
single-player action role-playing game
which will allow you to create your own
personal witcher wizard
and spec them exactly as you want them
to be anyway
if you want to learn more about the game
i've already made two videos on it which
you can check out on my channel
without further ado here's the leaked
[Music]
footage
so
[Music]
blue
you